[موسيقى]
زلزال التسريحات او عاصفه الاستقالات لا
فرق كلاهما ينظر بكارثه في تويتر فالدخول
من باب الشركه حتما ليس كخروجه
عدو هجران تويتر لم تقتصر على افراد
بعينهم بل ان شركات باسرها حولت مسارتها
الى منصه اخرى بسبب ترنح التطبيق على ايدي
الملياردير الامريكي الى مصر
ثم قال لبقيتهم اما ان تعملوا بتسال غير
مشروط والا فرحل وفعلا غادروا بلا ان ينظر
وراءهم ليتركوا الطائره الازرق لاجنحه
تعتصر الف موظف ما زالوا صامدين رغم انهم
قد يغيرون ارائهم لاحقا فالافلاس وارد في
ظل تراجع الاعلانات التي تمثل 90% من دخل
الشركه امام ماسك الذي يسر على ان عصفوره
حي يرزق ولا قفص سيذبح نشاطه يمطر
المستخدمين بغزاره تغريداته وبين الحين
والاخر يبدو انه يضمنها شيئا من حياته
الخاصه
اخرها حول امكانيه اعاده حساب المنظر
الامريكي وصاحبي نظريات المؤامره اليكس
جونز بشان مذبحه وقعت في مدرسه عام 2012
وراحه ضحيتها 28 طفلا لياتي الجواب صارما
ومستذكرا به مراره فقد ابنه الذي لم
يتجاوز ال 10 اسابيع هذا الغني المصنف
كاحد اثرياء العالم صدق وان صرح ايضا بانه
مشرد بلا منزل ياويه وحياته ليست مطرفه
كما يخير للبعض وبغض النظر الى ان العوده
الى احضان تويتر لم تكن برفع الحظر عن
الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب فحسب
وانما على مغني الراب الشهير كان يوست
الذي سبق واتهم بمعادته الساميه حينما
ارتدي قميصا كتب عليه حياه البيض مهمه
ليبدو ماسك بشكل او باخر متضامنا معه
ولمن لا يعرف فان الماسك الذي ولد في 28
من يونيو عام
1971 في بريتوريا امه كنديه وابوه من جنوب
افريقيا ذو اصول هولنديه وبريطانيه اي انه
ثلاثي الجنسيه اخرها حصوله على الامريكيه
قبل 20 سنه انا منه ترا رعت على حب
القراءه وكان شغوفا باجهزه الحاسوب وتطوير
البرمجيات لكنه مصاب بمتلازمه احد
اضطرابات الطيف التوحد اسبرجر التي وصفها
خبراء الصحه بانها قد تكون نقطه قوه في
انجازاته وابتكارته ماسك الذي ينوي ان
يحلق مع طائره الازرق بنسخه محدثه يقول
فيها وداعا لتويتر القديم
اسراء الصغير العربيه